und habt ihr verstanden was ich gerade
gesagt hat wahrscheinlich nicht es gibt
aber leute die lippen lesen können und
nur anhand der mundbewegungen verstehen
worüber jemand spricht selbst wenn sich
das ziel hinter einer glasscheibe oder
in einem auto befindet und man nichts
hören kann diese fähigkeiten stellen oft
agenten und spione in hollywood film
zuschauer in den meisten fällen
beherrscht diese fähigkeit aber eine
ganz andere zielgruppe warum kannst du
lippenlesen
[Musik]
das thema ist super faszinieren und ich
glaube auch wenn man nicht direkt darauf
angewiesen ist ist lippenlesen ein echt
cooler skill wie so ein geheimagent
verstehen was andere heimlich flüstern
oder bei sport und promi events
gespräche verstehen die eigentlich
niemand mitbekommen sollte es wäre schon
ziemlich krass abt kann das jeder
einfach zu lernen dieses video wird
unterstützt von display damit wir am
ende des experiments einen
vorher-nachher-vergleich haben und genau
messen können ob und wie sehr ich mich
verbessere haben sowie felix und luan
jeweils mehrere sätze aufgenommen deren
bedeutungen wir nun ohne ton verstehen
müssen wir sind in dem fall alle und ich
dann haben wir nämlich auch direkt einen
vergleich zwischen lippenleser anfänger
und profis
das
überraschenderweise sind ganz ganz kurze
sätze noch schwieriger als mittelsitz
auflösung ist ich kann gut kochen leute
ich hab ich erwarte
ich bin eine biene neue lady machst du
das
[Musik]
der himmel ist blau
ich wollte es auf ich habe thomas hat
einen mächtigen war ich hab thomas hat
einen sehr bilden war thomas hat einen
sehr wilden bart wie kann man das ist
normal
einfach auf den wolf das ist
[Musik]
wirklich
berührt und in der schule ich gehe auf
den balkon und setzten verfahren stehe
okay ich gehe auf dem balkon und setzte
mich auf einen stuhl
[Musik]
das ist
das ist ein richtig komplizierter sagt
eigentlich soll daneben stand gehabt die
werden das schon recht fünf sechs sieben
acht neun zehn elf wörtern also respekt
vor
[Musik]
die schattenseite stehen
ich vergebe gern gesehen ich hab' ich
liebe alle einen geht wieder okay lass
ich vergebe gerne die fehler hier weiß
man dass ich es nicht
so dass du das verstehst obwohl du nicht
mal den inhalt verstanden hast du schon
echt krass
[Musik]
ich habe heute nichts von schafen ich
habe heute viel zu schlafen
ich habe heute viel zu wird dir schlafen
das macht sie jetzt
also ich habe doch die theorie je länger
der satz lässt so merkt man was ich 1 1
in die lücken schließen habe ich die
anderen sachen die man versteht wer
hätte es gedacht alle ist viel besser
als ich ich muss also versuchen in nur
einer woche mit gezieltem training ihre
20 jahre erfahrung an unbewussten
lippenlesen aufzuholen auch wenn es
offensichtlich kein kompletter mythos
ist ist lippenlesen tatsächlich er einen
rätselraten bei dem man versucht aus den
lauten die man erkannt hat und dem
kontext sowie mimik körpersprache und
umgebung zusammen zu puzzeln was der
andere wohl gesagt hat eine
100-prozentige trefferquote hat aber
kein lippenleser deswegen benutzen die
meisten bürger schädigen das lippenlesen
er als eine ergänzende stütze das ist so
schwierig ist setzte nur das lippenlesen
zu erkennen liegt unter anderem daran
dass man dem deutschen nur 15 prozent
der laute eindeutig anhand der
mundbewegungen entziffern kann wenn ich
zum beispiel bot und brote habt ihr nur
anhand meiner lippen keine chance die
beiden wörter zu unterscheiden deswegen
ist der kontext so wichtig denn beim
bäcker wenn man mich wohl kaum
nachfragen ob ich ein boot kaufen will
aber auch wörter die sich eigentlich gar
nicht ähnlich klingen wie bruder und
montag lassen sich anhand der
mundbewegungen nur durch den minimalen
unterschied zwischen u und e
unterscheiden deshalb ist es wichtig die
laute die man überhaupt erkennen kann
auch wirklich zu erkennen und wenn ich
das aktiv lernen will hilft nur eins
übung in meiner recherche bin ich auch
so genannte im mund bilder gestoßen die
mir dabei helfen können erst ein gefühl
dafür zu bekommen wie einzelne laute auf
den lippen überhaupt aussehen und da die
literatur über das lippenlesen echt
mager ist ich weiß nicht soll ich die
dinge einmal ausdrücken wer com gesagt
getan ich drucke die und bilder aus und
schreibt den entsprechenden laut auf die
andere seite damit kann ich hoffentlich
lernen mit karteikarten und kann dieses
wissen dann vielleicht auch in echtzeit
beim sprechen anwenden und die frage
welcher laut war das noch gleich ist
geschichte wir sind mit überhaupt stimmt
kamera läuft verwendet damals spiegel
habe das sieht so aus wenn man so
richtig dicke schöne lippen hat er ja
wieder überhaupt nicht wer hat euch
litten die machen ja gar keinen sinn
meine zunge ist auch viel weiter unten
ich weiß nicht ob das so zu treffen so
wechseln sollen ich glaube es macht mir
sind einfach so einem handy zu üben und
zu schauen wie die wörter aussehen wenn
ich sie spreche ich glaube die
darstellungen sie nicht so realistisch
[Musik]
die beim üben vor dem spiegel merke ich
schon langsam kleine fortschritte es
gibt aber auch echte lippenleser
experten die das ganze gemeistert haben
und professionell stummfilmen oder
historischen aufnahmen wie der leben bzw
schon ein haufen so dass wir heute
teilweise verstehen können worüber sich
zum beispiel soldaten im schützengraben
unterhalten haben doch auch auf aktuelle
ereignisse werfen profi lippenleser
ihren blick besonders bei
fußballspielern wird unter dem hashtag
ablesen service regelmäßig verraten
welche beleidigungen sich die spieler so
an den kopf werfen und bei anderen
sportarten wie american football wo die
absprachen über den nächsten spielzug
entscheidend sind platzieren die teams
sogar mit ferngläsern ausgestattete
lippenleser im publikum um dem gegner
immer einen schritt voraus zu sein und
da ich nicht glaube dass mir diesem und
bilder überhaupt eben was bringen wir in
hälfte eins und zwar erfahrung sammeln
und das mache ich jetzt in dem ich
leuten besprechen zuschauer und zwar
ohne was zu hören mit untertiteln
wenigen wo maximal monaten schicken
herbert act für die wochenlang raus
gehört ohne zu lesen es sind aber immer
eigentlich eher einzelne wörter die man
erkennt ja gut das macht jetzt den rest
der woche
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt auf die idee gekommen dass
ich einfach wieder ohne untertitel den
ton an machen kann aber so leise dass
ich fast nix höher und dadurch muss ich
mir die ganzen rücknahme trickst
lippenlesen erschließen ich stelle mir
das so vor dass ich damit richtig gut
trainieren kann und den ton hier immer
immer leiser machen kann bis dann
irgendwann komplett sturm ist und nichts
trotzdem locker steht an bord ist lippen
lesen
[Musik]
so machen wir starten mit dem
was ich habe hat sich gesagt ich bin
voller sonne ich bin voll der trottel
beides nicht ich bin von allen zocken
was ich kenne ich überhaupt wollen
rocken
ich glaube dass ich heiße yuan und ich
bin auch mit dabei
der 3d drücken geht mir ziemlich auf die
nerven
zeigt der 3d drucker geht mit ziemlich
auf die nerven
ich verstehe nicht wie sie das macht
[Musik]
also ich glaube ist aber okay und ich
war immer ein frosch ich kann ich bin
ich auch bekommen hast du zu machen
heute ist der himmel bewölkt
heute ist der himmel bewölkt labors
heimlich nach bildern oder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also sicherlich aber sicher bin ich mir
nicht thomas haupt einem stock in der
hand das verstehe ich auf jeden fall
warum also ich hab thomas hat ein
schönes
ich wollte mir ein schönes regal weil er
selber gefahren der thomas hat keine
chance gegen alle
[Musik]
und mehr ein wort stimmt aber wer hat
meinen doktor geklaut das glaubt dass es
mache keinen sinn mehr soll es ein
doppelkern ich hab alles bis auf das
eine war dr ach gast wer hat meinhard
geklaut das macht sinn ja ja der hat
mein croissant geklaut aber gepäck
[Musik]
ich bin nicht zuversichtlich aber ich
hab nichts gar nichts und ich hab sie
nicht kaufe eine uhr dem was am ende mit
uhr können sie nicht jetzt habe ich
einfach hunger
lippenlesen ist ziemlich einfach oder
ja
ich sag mir nichts mehr gegen einen zug
läuft ist und jetzt mal nicht wer gegen
glas anläuft ist dumm aber
stark das ist super beeindruckend aber
ich freue mich halt dass ich jetzt auch
merke dass ich tatsächlich kann dieses
kreuz ich bin einfach schlechter
geworden ich glaub exil also es ist ein
bisschen so du hast dass wir dafür
bekommen
aber es ist halt halt das ist komplett
falsch ich habe quasi ein buchloer das
nächstbeste genommen aber jetzt so
richtig sicher wollen wir nicht so viel
steht fest man kann lippen lesen lernen
aber man braucht dafür 20 jahre und
nicht eine woche wir gemerkt hat ist für
mich lippenlesen nicht unbedingt die
einfachste art mit anderen zu
kommunizieren viel einfacher kann man
seine interessen und leidenschaften mit
display dem spiel des heutigen videos
ausdrücken display zum hochwertig auf
metall gedruckte motive zum aufhängen
und es gibt eine riesen auswahl an
motiven wirklich von jedem genre egal ob
fußballfan seit oder euer lieblings film
star wars ist bei display findet ihr
echt alles und das in verschiedenen
größen sowie im hoch und querformat weil
der enorme auswahl macht echt spaß nicht
einmal durchzuklicken wie ihr seht finde
ich naturmotive ziemlich nah ist und vor
allem dass hier im dschungel
displays lassen sich mit dem
einzigartigen magnetsystem superleicht
und vor allem gerade aufhängen
produziert wird übrigens in der eu und
eure bestellung kommt schon nach zwei
bis drei tagen verschickt werden
displays immerhin gut schützen den
verpackungen die beide auch richtig cool
design sind also klickt auf den link in
der beschreibung schaut euch mal an und
er bekommt sogar noch ein extra rabatt
die gute alle die mich beim lippenlesen
so abgezogen hat hat übrigens auf ihrem
verlinken youtube-kanal einige video zum
thema umwelt geschädigt sein wenn er das
interessiert hat unbedingt mal rein und
damit sein
[Musik]